[Música]
[Aplausos]
estaré aquí
bueno vamos al grano dice que el ceder
no se olvida seguramente cuando tiene
algo reparado
lo anterior que ha pasado son olvidar al
médico apenas mujeres tu nuevo
smartphone no ser ultra mega cruz ya no
te acuerdas
[Música]
tu fondo de pantalla
bueno
[Música]
bueno ese es uno mismo
y bueno eso dice
cada cosa mejorada que llega a nuestra
vida saca de la versión antigua de un
sopetón como el claro por saco por clave
que si eres de televisión y un plasma de
150 pulgadas nunca te vas a volver
acostumbrar nunca vas a ver una película
en un televisor en tango llegó de hecho
de poquísima gente
donde las funciones de control remoto la
saciedad tu hermanito menor
[Música]
yo
así que ahora que lo separó de mis
hermanos durante muchos años
vamos a ver
[Música]
y bueno
repito cuando hay una de las vidas de la
gente la gente se olvida de lo anterior
otros como yo tenemos problemas para
delimitar los de las cosas para los que
compramos nuevo sea un celular una
impresora un halago agarrando del
viejito
[Música]
y el sueño
tengo problemas para romper vínculos y
estoy empezando a sospechar que si todos
los días paso por la sala y una mirada
cariñosa a mi imagen de civil o liberty
color rata
la regla absoluta de riesgo mismas
evitas
como podrán notar muchas cosas que ahora
serían antiguas y de hecho el día
[Música]
bueno
pero tengo dificultades para
dejar las cosas hacer un mes ya me pongo
a alguien fue mi vida lo vio
es decir me lo quitó de mi vida amorosa
otra vez
y
pero
dificultades para poder
pero bueno
me creerá en dejar atrás muchas cosas
no hablo de tecnologías que se fueron
volviendo obsoletas y que no parecen
verdaderas revoluciones me creerán si
les dijo que conoció un lindo tipo y
bueno tampoco voy a explicarlo los
mayores de 50 pero este era un proceso
complicadísimo por el que se imprimían
los periódicos hace medio siglo
imagínense un salón enorme subterráneo
donde unos señores como los de la foto
armaban unas cajitas con unos
cuadraditos de plomos con las letras al
revés que servían para luego imprimirlas
en unas rotativas gigantescas de ese
mismo tipo
y de esa resultemos donde producir e
imprimir y difundir una noticia tomada
cientos de personas literalmente cientos
desde el periodista que ha recabado la
noticia que era una puerta de toda la
máquina de producción aquí estoy yo en
mi papel de turkish está alguna vez
cuando tenía 20 años y hasta el
canillita estoy segura que nadie se
juega de la orden y está pero entonces
dos años o algo que los periodistas
reservamos con terquedad y es el axioma
de nuestra vida el periodismo es una
forma de acercarse a la verdad de los
hechos y transmitirla con la mayor
honestidad posible
eso nos enseñaron que eso hemos tratado
de hacer a lo largo de nuestras vidas
pero en algún momento de este siglo algo
fue cambiando la verdad de esa que
creíamos el vellocino de oro de nuestra
carrera comenzó a desdibujarse desde
nuestros ojos de pronto ya no podíamos
distinguirla en medio de un mar de
excesos de verdades
literalmente como la biblia buscar la
verdad comenzó a resultar más difícil
que buscar una aguja en un pajar que es
la verdad todos hemos oído hablar de
alguna vez la voz verdad no es una
mentira tampoco la rada obviamente es
una falsa verdad creada por gente que no
trata de llegar a tu cerebro a tu lado
racional sino a tus emociones
estaba de alguna manera empacada para
que sea muy verosímil
la más verdad pero me estoy adelantando
él
la verdad es como una especie de aluvión
cada día al oscar en la avalancha
y vienen de todos lados de whatsapp de
instagram de marcha y de repente linda
no tengo dinero
pero se puede detectar que es difícil
aquí algunos algunos tips para cuando le
lleguen una noticia y puedan darse
cuenta
y es una verdad
primero primero que nada destruir
desconfía porque estas noticias no sólo
las regué los medios tradicionales o en
twitter se le manda a un amigo de
repente hasta su hermano alguien en
quien confía y usted dirá cómo no voy a
creerle pues no hay que creerle porque
esa persona también puede estar
contaminada con la post verdad nadie
está libre
desbordando también
analiza desde el segundo tipo analizar
su reacción ante una noticia hay que
observarse cuando más fuerte sea tu
rabia o tu pena o tu indignación ante
una noticia y más probable que estés
ante una mujer nada
sospecha siempre de los que se creen o
de los que aparentan ser los dueños
absolutos de la verdad
porque cuando menos
este es esto es un estudio realizado
cuando menos alguien sabe del tema más
creo y se llama efecto temprano y
recuerde lo y está en wikipedia y dices
es los objetivos según el cual los
individuos con escasa habilidad o
conocimientos sufren de un sentimiento
de superioridad del usuario
considerándose más inteligentes que
otras personas preparadas
esto que suena paradójico es real cuando
menos sabes de un tema más tierras a los
poquitos que saben y por tanto estás más
seguro
cuando sentimos
un poco aburrido pero es necesario
verificar fechas pueden desautorizan
medios serios instituciones científicas
que respalden aquello que estás leyendo
periodistas con credibilidad de las
redes tomate trabajos vale la pena
y quinto lo más importante pregúntate a
quién beneficia una post verdad apenas
la hayas ubicada puede ser un loquito
digital tratando de burlarse de la
ingenuidad de la gente de cierto mucha
gente cree eso pero también puede ser
alguien que está haciendo un gran
negocio con esa ingenuidad o peor aún
alguien que está tratando de torcer una
voluntad política
de fácil la verdad tiene un axioma que
es creo luego estoy en lo correcto
cuando tengo que estar muy seguro la
verdad en un axioma que tiene muchos
siglos
pienso luego existo un poco más difícil
del más efectivo
por eso digo el periodismo ha cambiado
porque ahora además de esta nuestra
misión de siempre de buscar la verdad de
los hechos y transmitirla con la mayor
honestidad posible tenemos que batirnos
con la post verdad
que desenmascarar la verdad
cómo
chequeando datos verificando
contrastando es un trabajo a veces poco
sexy de repente nos a menos lectores o
televidentes pero es lo que nos
enseñaron a seguir lo que hemos hecho a
lo largo de nuestras vidas
pero la gente preferirá creernos a
nosotros o preferir a aferrarse a sus
verdades tan seductoras esas que
legalice en los oídos que tocan sus
miedos profundos sus preocupaciones
bueno eso depende de algo que es una
joya preciada que es algo muy frágil
que se llama credibilidad
que además es un atributo que cada
periodista se construye a lo largo de su
vida con su capacidad con su honestidad
sobre todo con su calidad como ser
humano
no sabemos si david vencer a goliat
sin embargo
y este es el gobierno que esté sea cual
sea la religión que esté de moda
por muchos terroristas o anti vacunas
que hay en el mundo
ser fuente creíble de información será
alguien en quien la gente cuya opinión y
es muy información la gente puede
confiar es ese gran valor que los
periodistas buscamos a lo largo de toda
nuestra vida
y eso no ha cambiado desde los tiempos
del linotipo ni hace 20 años ni hace 30
ni hace 40 por eso les digo por eso les
aseguro que la post verdad no va a poder
con nosotros muchas gracias
[Música]